it's interesting because i'm going to
this a to e conference on thursday which
is ted's artist entrepreneur conference
up in san francisco and one of the
things I'm supposed to do is say is in
three minutes which I said are you
kidding three minutes me and then they
said oh you want it shorter or longer
it's like well considering I usually
talk for two days you know non-stop I
think three minutes is probably going to
be pretty tough for me so I don't think
I've ever said anything in three minutes
which is you know one of my initial
issues with twitter is i have a hard
time talking in short fights but you
know it's kind of like what's the most
exciting thing that's happened in the
last year in your opinion and to me it's
filmmakers embracing the notion of
serialized content that and not thinking
about like Amy if you want to put in
simplistic terms of filmmakers thinking
about moving towards the television
model from a film model and just like
the more exciting things happening in
drama or a lot of the more exciting
things in drama are happening not out of
feature films studio films but are
happening in television or things that
are similar to television that I think
the web is starting to mature where
filmmakers can find satisfying creative
expression with serialized form which is
the natural wood actual form towards
engaging audience on a regular basis
than a feature film and to me what I
started saying in a lot of workshops now
our interviews is that I think we're
going to get to the point where only
making a feature film is like using a
rotary dial phone that you know it's
more and more filmmakers have to
understand that a feature film is one
form that was developed a century ago
and that today in order to engage
audiences while the future form is still
satisfying and i still like watching
features it's not the only media form
that
want to connect with and many audiences
don't have the time for 90 minutes don't
won't engage you on a feature you know
and that you want to think about the
different ways that you can connect with
audiences that will work around a
feature film and will involve the
feature film but that if you're only
thinking that you're going to make a
feature film you're going to get that
out into the world you're to me kind of
shooting yourself in the foot because
you're not preparing for all the other
kinds of audience engagement that might
be possible so for instance in obama to
which is a releasing as a feature soon
started as a web series and was born on
the web as a web series and in that I
figured well let's just try to put it
together see if it fits together as a
feature and which it did and because I
have certain ways to monetize content
set up through vomit one and there
seemed to be an interest of vomit to
that I could actually make some
additional revenue from releasing vomit
to in addition to the money that I made
creating it as a web series so but when
I made it into a feature I also realized
that I had shot a bunch of extra
material and so we create we created ten
other pieces of content that we're going
to use to help promote the release of
vomit too in addition to that we're also
going to do an online web contest you
know for people to submit their videos
from all over the world of graffiti and
street art we're going to do a video
contest and a still contest at a still
image contest and where the winners are
actually going to end up on the bomb it
dbd so in a sense it's kind of a form of
contest crowdsourcing and you know and
so that's if I only thought about vomit
as a feature film I feel like I would
really hamper you know my vision of how
it can engage audiences in a sense and
you know i think the real
forward-thinking filmmakers like Tiffany
Shlain and and got a keeper joseph
gordon
that you know who I say visionary
filmmaker through his hit record program
who are engaging audiences in
interesting ways and EDD Byrnes does it
to to an extent in terms of involving
their audience in the creation you know
and this is something that's been around
for a while you know Star Trek Teemu
from Finland did it with Star Trek and
as well with iron sky but I think
there's you know more and more
interesting ways to do this and I think
you know that's just one example of how
filmmakers should and can get beyond the
feature form and if you look at Tiffany
you know a lot of her success has come
not through features but through shorts
and through things that you know aren't
one thing or another you know there's no
label for them so I think more and more
you know and I teach at film school and
it's you know and there's this still
within students there's this notion of
the feature film but you have to really
look at the modern audience and is that
all they want to consume and is that
even the primary thing that they want to
consume you know and that's not saying
that you can't tell stories in a in
utilizing you know the moving image but
I think it's important for filmmakers to
kind of rican sep Schewel eyes how they
tell stories
you